when hurricane Lily hit the Louisiana
Shore back in 2002 it didn't do much
damage but it did leave meteorologists
at the National Hurricane Center very
confused this a loop behind me you can
see Lily coming in across Cuba it became
a category 4 hurricane right here in the
central Gulf of Mexico but then it
weakened down to a category 1 hurricane
at landfall dr. max Mayfield is the
former director of the National
Hurricane Center he says that over the
years his team got better and better at
predicting a hurricane struck but what
we don't do a good job at is catching
the rapidly changing hurricanes the ones
that rapidly intensify like lily and the
ones that rapidly diminished like Lily
did before landfall and being able to
predict a Hurricanes intensity is
vitally important you really do have to
know the intensity of the hurricane
because the evacuation plans are based
on not just where the hurricane is going
to hit but on how strong it is and
there's a big big difference between the
category 1 hurricane that might have 4
to 5 feet of storm surge person and the
category 5 hurricane that could have
above 20 feet of storm surge learning
what factors ultimately help in
predicting a hurricane strength is the
first step
one factor in helping to predict how
strong a hurricane could be the Saharan
air layer this is the warm dusty air
that blows off of Africa the dust in the
Saharan air layer can actually act to
change the microphysics in the clouds
and actually reduce the hurricane
activity and even the thunderstorm
activity it can also warm the Saharan
air layer and create what we call a
temperature inversion which makes it
very hard for the thunderstorm tops to
bubble up through the atmosphere it also
contains a lot of strong winds that
create vertical wind shear and very dry
air that really knocks the punch takes a
punch out of hurricanes Jason Dunn ioan
is meteorologist with NOAA's hurricane
research division he believes the
Saharan air layer is a major force in
predicting which hurricanes boom and
which ones go bust researchers can now
see both the hurricane and the Saharan
air layer at the same time we can track
the Saharan air layer seeing it here in
orange and yellow and hurricane Aaron
and you can see that the system actually
becomes enveloped by the Saharan air
layer and this could be one of the
reasons why this system struggled early
on but later in the time period you can
see Aaron pops out of the Saharan air
layer and rapidly intensifies into a
major hurricane the next step is for
researchers to learn more about the
Saharan air layer with this new
satellite technology that we have we can
actually track this hair in air layer
and send our know and airforce hurricane
hunters out to the Saharan air layer and
sample it using GPS drop wind signs and
they can help us measure the strong
winds and very dry air in the air layer
and that may help us understand how the
Saharan air layer interacts with
hurricanes and ultimately this research
is all about making our lives a lot
safer